truppenübungsplatz 1 steigt die vierte
panzergrenadierbrigade bringt sich für
die übung handwerk in stellung
übungsannahme ist das ausschalten schwer
bewaffneter terroristen die mit
panzerabwehrraketen zunächst gegen die
anrückende polizei vorgehen die sich
daraufhin zurück sieht über wenn das
innenministerium der polizei nicht mehr
weiter kann dann ist das österreichische
bundesheer dann sind die soldatinnen und
soldaten zur stelle und sie sind auch im
internationalen vergleich durchaus sehr
angesehen schweres geschütz in der
kampfpanzer leopard kommt zum einsatz
das lager der terroristen wird und
stellt und von panzergrenadieren
schließlich gestürmt und geräumt
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
ist bei dieser übung nicht nur dabei
sondern sprichwörtlich mittendrin in
einem panzer unglaublich professionell
was die vierte panzergrenadierbrigade
hier gezeigt hat ich habe das nicht das
erste mal gesehen aber mit einem panzer
war ich das erste mal auch mit mit an
bord sehr beeindruckend was hier
geleistet worden ist immer zum schutz
auch von österreich und der
österreicherinnen und österreicher